you know they've got the toyota grand
prix of long beach the celebrity race
right the pro celebrities i end up doing
it i end up winning the next year they
invite me to come back as the previous
winner they tell me that i got to start
at the back of the pack i was in first
place in four laps their 25th
anniversary they invite me back they
invite a bunch of like previous winners
i didn't get the call by the way you you
were probably busy that weekend
actually that would have been before you
were you were racing all right i feel
less slighted
anyway i went into turn one no breaks
because i put my foot to the floor
nothing happened i grabbed the e-brake
pull it up and kind of get the car to
rotate so i went in sideways and didn't
take the front out so then i just used
the gears and the e-brake the rest of
the way no you didn't i finished third
no you didn't i don't even think i could
have done that
this podcast exists because i love
talking to people and i love going deep
the purpose is to plant seeds of
inspiration we enter a space of
vulnerability and relatability and what
you realize is that we are so much more
alike than we are different to quote
ramdas we're all just walking each other
home and this show is just one step i'm
danica patrick and i'm pretty intense
[Music]
i'm so happy to have alfonso ribeiro on
the pretty intense podcast today
i've known alfonso for a really long
time we met about 25 years ago at a
go-kart track and when i met him he was
just finishing up a little show called
fresh prince of bel-air where he played
carlton banks and trust me he does still
does the dance till today
i've seen him do it many times we
finally had the time to like really go
into these experiences and the memories
of racing go-karts he really has some
some really great perspectives on life
but he's just a really really happy
positive guy i have no doubt that as you
listen to this podcast you will be
smiling too and if this podcast doesn't
get you to smile i know that watching
america's funniest home videos which
comes out in october uh nat geo will get
you to smile because who has not watched
america's funniest home videos i used to
watch that all the time so have fun with
this episode
we're rolling
and we're rolling that's the that would
be literally the most official start of
a podcast that i will have ever had
kind of freak people out because usually
i just start talking about something
that just came up like something natural
and then we start going and every now
and again somebody goes oh have we
started i'm like
yeah yeah they're like oh um take two
and i'm like not really but okay yeah
yeah no that that whole beginning is
still gonna be on air yes well that
whole thing and still yeah this too
well that's that's the reality to me is
like you know because i've done a few of
these in the past right where the moment
you absolutely come on
you recognize oh this is where we're
going
like it's never a all right let's get
started i'm like oh we haven't started
okay we can
just i just assume we're going
that's but that's smart see you're
seasoned you've done
a billion interviews
not a billion like like 100 million yeah
sorry i overestimated it do you ever get
sick of them though i mean like i
totally got sick of them like at the end
of my racing career i was like god these
are just the most
these are different to me but like
regular interviews i'm like
the the ones that are the hardest for me
are the smt those and i wouldn't say
this i'm tired of them they're just
harder to do
because you start out with all the zest
and the energy of whatever it is that
you're trying to promote and you want to
talk about it but then all of a sudden
like you're two and a half hours in and
you're like
yep i've said this 25 times already for
people that don't know on smt satellite
media tours where you sit down in a
chair they've got a camera in front of
you
and every i mean it's different leap
report like i've had them every seven
minutes before i've had them every 10
i've had them every 15 but they're
they're just one after another and so
usually they want like two hour windows
for them and i hit my threshold at about
90 minutes i i i can make the two hours
and and so like we've tried to get the
two hours to be the max but every once
in a while it's like three
and
the you know the radio tours are easier
because you can literally move around
the house yeah you're like you know yeah
you know you don't have to look any way
you don't have to exactly keep your [ __ ]
together you can yeah yeah you're not
you're not here you're not looking into
the green light
right let's pretend like i'm not here
that's the magic just pretend like i'm
not here do whatever you'd normally do
just look into the green light
[Laughter]
and keep saying the same stuff over and
over again
but yeah you know it's like i said so i
don't get tired of them because it's
like i still
feel blessed that i get to do these
right like i mean obviously there's a
like there's a reason right that i get
to do it and i'm lucky enough to do it
so i
i kind of put it together in that way i
kind of go yeah well you know what i get
to do these you know yeah you know you
hate the ones where they misquote you or
they you know i i like it when
it's more like this right like so you
know this will go out and it will be my
words with me on camera saying whatever
i'm saying in an entirety an entirety
right a setup here's the story here's
the like the whole thing versus
you you say something and they
let me go take that line and put it over
here and move it around and
those are the ones that you don't you
don't enjoy where did you where did you
get your humor like i mean where did
that come from is it
uh cultivated is it i mean it's got to
be a lot natural was your dad funny your
mom
my mom and dad aren't funny at all
oh well that's kind of funny actually
they would they'd probably be like what
i'm funny um no you're not um
i i would just say i think being the
baby
of the bunch right so i'm the youngest
of three boys
i think i had to find humor
in things because it was just a lot of
mayhem right growing up with all three
of us um and so if there's any place
that it came from it would be just kind
of like i was the kid who just was like
yeah whatever and just i found the
you know i i've always been glass half
full kind of guy and i think that really
lends itself to my brand of comedy
whereas there are the guys who and women
who are glass half empty and that's the
source of their comedy right it comes
from a dark place mine comes from a very
happy light
fun
you know enjoying life you know even
when things aren't good in my life i'm
still enjoying life and i think that
that
take on everything allows me to dive
deeper into just
trying to bring a lightness of fun a
happiness to every situation that i'm in
you know even if you're talking about a
serious situation i'm probably going to
make a joke somewhere because i'd rather
everybody kind of light
and open than than not and i would say
that that i've used it mostly
in my life as a director
because when you're directing and
everybody's in the process and
everybody's trying to figure out what
they want to do and how they want to say
something sometimes that moment lighting
it up just just taking the pressure out
of the moment and putting it on me and
taking it away from everybody just
allows them to go oh and they breathe
and then all of a sudden i feel like
especially with younger people when i
was working for you know disney
they would they would absolutely give
you a better performance and the
performance would be just a lot happier
and lighter and especially with disney
channel you wanted that kind of energy
right where everybody felt light and i
felt like i was able to to really kind
of help with that lightness and and just
you know
when i when i read things when i hear
things uh i i
i connect it and i connect it to a lot
of the stuff that i always do it's all
regurgitated
humor
something that i saw somebody i you know
i connected to you know eddie murphy or
right richard pryor you know um robin
williams you know i would i would i
would look at these comedy routines and
then all of a sudden i wouldn't say what
they're saying
but the essence of the way they
delivered it would show itself up in
something else that i would be doing
that may not at all be connected but the
essence of whatever that needed to be i
would try to drive that into that scene
wow
how
cool too that you went at from the
positive standpoint of comedy versus the
negative is that just the way or you are
or is that uh or can you identify where
that came from was there was there like
a heaviness in the house that you wanted
to lighten up was it your was your were
your brothers serious like did you just
choose that lane uh based on environment
or was this is this just very innate i
think i think it's mostly innate i think
it is it is a large part of just who i
am as a person
um in in growing up you know my brothers
and i we fought all the time like
physically yes all the time right we
were three boys my oldest brother is
three years older than me so right and
there's three of us so we were a bang
bang bang and at that age it's like
you're constantly wrestling you're
constantly fighting you're constantly
arguing right there's there was a lot of
that in in my in my house and
like i used to always say like in school
i became famous because i was in the
principal's office
when a phone call came in about a
broadway show called the tap dance kid
because i had just been in a fight
right so i i was that kid right i used
to always laugh because when i would see
you
right at races and somebody might hit
you and take you out and i would see you
just storming down pit lane ready to go
take on some dude who's twice your size
and i was like yeah i recognize that
person
right i was always the shortest kid in
the class i was the smallest guy right
but i used to always say yeah you might
win
but you but you're gonna have to fight
to win
and you better watch your ankles
okay okay yo i'm gonna hit you straight
in the gut um but
but like that was something that i dealt
with but i but i was still a bright
light i still was like no we're gonna
try to like have fun and i always wanted
to have fun but but you know kids can be
mean sometimes and so i i literally i
fought three times a week in grade
school
um
it was just part of what it was and i
used to always say yeah but you know
what you i'm gonna try to make sure you
never do it again because you know what
the end result is gonna be the end
result is gonna be that you're gonna be
in the fight
so you're not just going on you could
have gone mma
good well you could not you could have
gone a whole different direction yeah
but they would have needed a little pee
wee mma league
categories
yeah you know but i was thick
so
i still had the weight just not the
the physical
who wants to starve themselves that much
anyway just to like weigh in
when will smith was doing ali
um oh we actually went and spent
um
i spent probably six months with them
training um with angelo dundee and all
of these heavyweight boxers and so i
spent six months like learning to box
and we'd have to fight once a week in
the gym and so you know
well that sounds fair well no i would
have to fight him no other people in the
gym um but the weird thing is i end up
fighting like the one guy that i'd fight
all the time was 300 pounds but he was
my size at 300 pounds so it was i got to
hit him four times to take one punch
and but like that kind of training
that's it's not for everybody it's not
for everybody
yeah yeah i never i never tried boxing i
think i took like one kickboxing class
one time about 10 years ago and i mostly
just did like burpees with the with the
i did burpees hold with the boxing
gloves on then i come up and you plunge
and you go back down
wasn't real boxing but that's that's
like that's like billy blanks ish
yes exactly right something like that
something like that we did we i did a
lot of that too so
i mean didn't we all do those dvd things
back in the day of course i mean doesn't
anybody remember p90x insanity i used to
actually go
into billy blank's class oh oh
oh it was here in l.a so like you know
why put on the thing i'ma go i'm gonna
go hang out with billy and his brother
michael and we'd go in and train and
whatever this is the part of the story
when it's like how do we know each other
it's like we've known each other for so
long 25 years yes absolutely it's like
14 so that'd be 25 years for those who
can do math that's a bummer but if you
can't
let it go um but i i mean so where did
go-karting fit into this and then we're
going to talk about how we met yes so um
go-karting came in after
actually a while after i started racing
so
i started at 18
and
you know they've got the toyota grand
prix of long beach the celebrity race
right the pro celebrates and
the the the first time i actually just
went it was ricky schroeder because i
was doing silver spoons i had done
silver spoons he did the race they let
me practice up at willow springs and
they let me just hop in the car on the
fourth day of practice and i ended up
going faster than everybody who had been
actually practicing for four days a
little just hopped in the car and then
faster than everybody i was like that
that was fun
um so a couple years later they invite
me to do it
i end up doing it i end up winning um
and i kind of clock out and literally
just disappear from the rest of the
celebrity field the next year they
invite me to come back as the previous
winner they tell me that i gotta start
at the back of the pack as a pro
but not as a pro yet oh at the back of
the celebrity just the back of the
celebrity field so even though i
qualified up front they put me at the
back of the celebrity field i was in
first place in four laps oh god
right so
i just went through the field and
literally almost every turn i passed
somebody and just in four laps i was in
the lead
so the next year they invite me back
again and it's their 25th anniversary
they invite me back they invite a bunch
of like previous winners
um they give me a car
i didn't get the call by the way you you
were probably busy that weekend
you might have been um actually that
would have been before you were you were
racing yeah i did it in 2001. yeah this
was like 96.
okay all right i feel less slighted
anyway um so so
i went into turn one
no breaks
i mean there's runoff but what a bummer
no it was a wall
it was a wall but i used the e-brake
because i put my foot to the floor
nothing happened i grabbed the e-brake
pull it up
and kind of
get the car to rotate so i went in
sideways and didn't take the front out
so then i just used
the gears and the e-brake the rest of
the way no you didn't yes
i finished third no you didn't
i don't even think i could have done
that well i just was like that was i
wasn't gonna stop i was like let me just
try and it you know you had to break way
earlier right so next up drifting yeah
well i tried that i'm not that good at
that
but so from there i was like well let me
just do some other stuff right and i'd
done something had the dodge neon
um celebrity series and different stuff
and then i decided i wanted to try to
give it a real run so i went and i did
the barbara dodge pro series i did the
star mazda series um so i did my first
oval at las vegas motor speedway in the
in the star mazda series i did a bunch
of road courses laguna seca sears point
um
and did okay you know and and uh and
then i ended up having a pretty bad
crash
um at a street circuit in reno in the
barbie dodge car
and so that kind of derailed me moving
forward in real cars but i wasn't done
racing
i still had the bug right so
um
someone like that we knew was like oh
you should try go-karting and i was like
you know all right let's try go-karting
and then i like found out really what
go-karting was like and i went ooh this
could be this this could still
give me what i want in the racing world
right i can still go and and and bust
and go hard and so i i ended up finding
a team and sean patrick flannery and
myself and mark paul gossler and perry
king and a bunch of us decided we were
all going to do a little bit of this and
so we we ended up getting go-karts and
we ended up
teaming up with tony cart
right which is where which is leading
into us right so we ended up with the
guy who
would import all the tony cart chassis
into america john the main jean jean
marcioni right so but we
almost funded him
right which meant you funded me
which this is where
our circles cross because
we've been at supernationals in vegas
we went ahead and we basically put that
massive tent we paid for it
at at super nats in vegas
and
you ended up in our tent
in las vegas at 14 years old 14 years
old
while we were basically out there trying
to do the s1 s2 class and and run with
all the big boys the the problem is we
always felt like um the engine program
at
at tony cart was nowhere near everybody
else's um whenever we'd go and put our
motor on someone else's dyno uh it was
like i don't see the difference between
this and a stock motor
um so we we just never were able to
compete as we felt like we could yeah
you know scott speed was part of that
time when he was racing and
you know we ended up leaving tony carr
but we that's where we met you were you
were 14
and out there and you were just as
spunky as as your whole that was the
beginning of seeing like you turn into
like yeah go get it girl
yeah what i mean i'm i don't normally
ask questions uh about me but what do
you i don't even i mean i was 14 i don't
remem what i remember is of course like
how cool it was that like you
and we called i mean obviously mark paul
being zack for those who don't know mark
paul gosselin zach from save by the bell
and then sean patrick flannery we called
powder because he wasn't actually he did
a movie called powder right right
and so and like my sister and i and
there's like i can remember this picture
uh that we had all together hanging out
around the go-kart but i just remember
thinking how cool it was i was like wow
these people are into racing but the
question i have just because you were
there back then
i don't even what was i like i don't
well
what i remember most was you kind of you
you were shy-ish
right in the beginning like you were you
were i guess you were probably a little
with with them mostly but probably a
little star struck and kind of like oh
my god they're here that's kind of weird
it was but it was always that right it
was always a bit of the you know
why are they here right like yeah that's
a very much the question why are you
here what are you doing
world crossing that doesn't make sense
to people right
um
but you but but like because we were all
together in that tent we we would go out
and watch all the other races and i
remember watching you in one of the
races and going
oh she can drive
like she's got that fire and i think
when you would come back in we were you
know we were like dude girl that was
awesome and you were kind of like yeah
whatever and it was like you had like it
wasn't
it wasn't a good race but we were
impressed by it okay and
but that but that's where you like for
me
you gain the respect because it no
longer mattered that we were who we were
you were like i didn't have the race
that i wanted
it didn't matter who else was around
right right it wasn't like i was like
thanks that's really i was like whatever
yeah you were like
the race didn't didn't go
exactly as we planned it you watch i'm
like i probably was like did you watch
the race did you see what i'd i yeah of
course
right and it was like but to us it was
like
you know especially because
if i remember correctly there were
literally only like three or four girls
that maybe were there right there was a
girl from canada that raised julianna
juliana um there was you
um and like every once in a while
you'd see another person come in and now
that'd be about it but but really
unfortunately they would most likely
always be kind of at the back and so but
you were the you were you two were the
ones that were like in there competing
like
like okay yeah
you get next to each other it was good i
mean i was better but she was good she
was good she was good and and like what
was interesting was her and i
had many run-ins
really oh a ton
oh my god i have a story too about a run
with her what was your run
well we we ended up we were in the same
class
so
we ended up like
we were in
barry ontario
she was canadian she was canadian so it
was her kind of home race she was a big
part of helping get scusa there
and so
you know she was expected to win yeah
and she was they were part i think her
family was imported the burrell carts
right right right so they were it was a
big factory
right for them to to to do something
and we went into one of the heats
and
she bumped me out of the way
okay
i mean if we can now draw in the
beginning of this conversation about
fighting in school it's like if you want
to fight me i just you don't know how
this goes i mean this
you bump me out of the way
i mean
a couple corners later
that's quick
she got bumped out of the way
and we we get in after the heat she ends
up finishing near the back she and she
and like she storms down
right and up in my face gives me the
shove and i was like
like i can't do anything here you're
like i'm still
i'm a grown-up
yeah i used to hear that back in the day
about me they're like you can't start a
fight cause i can't fight you back i
can't like i can't but like different
when you're an adult like it's still
male female uncool can't do it
but i was also an adult yeah the kid
like
what
how does this yell at a 13 year old how
does this end right and she i think she
was a little she was probably like 17.
yeah she was probably in the seniors
class so she was at least
right but i was like i can't i can't we
can't but i okay
right and
i was like
beat it
in the next race whatever but you know
but she but she was a fighter she was a
hardcore
go after it get it done you know trying
to win every race um had that you know
canadian
uh you know uh a french canadian fire
and and you know but but what i remember
most about you was that you ultimately
was a hardcore go get it take no bull
um racer and it was like immediate
respect and
and i've always said and that laughingly
i was like well you know
danica used to race for me
you should tell that story i need to
know that sir i didn't know that story i
was like
yeah at the supernational she came and
she was under our tent and we had the
whole because we were we were basically
funding tony card so like we were that
week
basically funding the entire operation
and that was the year that jean decided
to do a i mean we had the biggest tent
by a long shot i mean there were 30
carts under the tent so
you know after that i think we ended up
i feel like i remember like my dad
thought there's too many people in there
so we got our we like moved out of the
tent and like got our own space because
it was just like too much and not enough
attention and
and so yeah we we moved out but my
julianna story is fairly similar i think
i was racing somewhere in maybe indiana
or something and
she bumped me and then the race finished
and i didn't get back to her so
afterwards i i was close enough and
after the checkered flag i just came up
behind her and slammed her so hard and
sent her off
and
you know it's really you know it
shouldn't matter i'm gonna say it
shouldn't matter but um after the
checkered flag they don't usually they
don't like you to um do those kinds of
things so okay
yeah it's always the second offender do
you really always notice that like then
you look at all of sports you look at
sports you look at racing i can think of
all kinds of times with myself and my
sport but you look at it and the
antagonizer
doesn't get in trouble absolutely it's
the retaliation that gets in trouble and
that's just not fair well i you know i
i've just i've just said i'm just gonna
accept it i'm not gonna stop doing it
like i was like yeah the second the
second person gets in more trouble
okay oh well okay but it's going to
happen
right and you know i mean obviously as
you as you continue to do amazing um
like
there is a there's a very difficult
reality that's very different in racing
than it is in many aspects of the world
um where i believe like
you had to hit her
i know what you mean right like you like
that moment the next time you two come
together on a racetrack
like she's gotta think just for a split
second
can i do this
because i know what the end result is
gonna be it's coming back
unless it was clean unless it was fair
it's coming back
yeah i remember this this this it
honestly felt like a burden because it's
not my nature like i don't love being
overly aggressive and taking people out
and it's not my nature i like to be fair
and i remember in nascar especially with
bumpers that when people would do stuff
to me there was this really big pressure
around me where
it was like you better do something
about that you better go take them out
you better and it was like ah and you
know for anybody who watched me
i didn't always execute very well
i sometimes took myself out
and then like one of the times where i
got hit by a driver and then i came back
out it was at martinsville and i hit
him back and tried to take him out but i
took myself out right and um i
that was the race
that matt kenzeth and joey logano had it
out and matt kenseth came back on the
track after he had been taken out and
and crashed joey logano and he was in
the running for the championship and um
it was because
logano did it to him the race before at
michigan and so because nascar was under
such high scrutiny scrutiny for what
what kenseth did um i'm sort of
blanketing myself in this is that i got
a huge point like i think i got fined
like seventy thousand dollars and got
like six months probation for it i mean
like i had a huge fine for it all
because it was kind of under this really
highly scrutinized race about since i
was not it was not for position with him
just like matt and joey weren't for
position all of a sudden it turned into
this big thing but yeah it's just not
fair in general but it's the way it goes
and i think i mean
you know that's probably a good attitude
just you have to you're right in racing
you do kind of have to stand up for
yourself so there's a second thought but
i think that
i don't think it's just racing i think
in life if somebody
does you wrong
and you have to sort of correct it there
might be some sort of repercussion of
that but that person better think twice
before they screw you over again or say
something negative to you
and you know i mean it's um you're not
about words you know words are cheap
going all the way back to my childhood
it's the same thing
right it's the same reality that i had
growing up where if you're going to
attack me
you gotta know what's coming back
and as long as you know what's coming
back the next time you're gonna think
before you do it and all you need is the
thought i don't it's not about
intimidation it's not about any of that
it's about i want you to know
because there are bullies in the world
and those bullies
they thrive on knowing you're not going
to do anything
and so for me i kept i always looked at
it like well
you're gonna have to do something
because
you're gonna attack i'm gonna respond
and now what
where where where are you are you really
the bully or do you sell wolf tickets
good luck which one is it
because if you're really the bully then
you're gonna stand up to the fight there
are a lot of guys and you know very
different in nascar because you have
bumpers right indy car that y'all don't
play that right that's not a game you
play because that's people lose their
lives um in go karting you gotta have
bumpers it's open wheel but it's bumpers
so it's kind of an in-between but you
constantly you know especially in the
like you always get bumped in the back
yeah that's an almost always case right
so um i just i i think just through life
i've i've just always been that
that fighter that wants to
live a happy life and i just want to be
left alone in that
world of like just don't attack i'm
never going to attack anybody
right i was like whenever i accidentally
bumped somebody at the end of the race i
don't care whether i ended up winning
losing
back of the field the first thing i
would do is walk up and go my bad just
immediately i'm letting you know that
was an accident that is not my intention
i was not trying to take you out i'm
sorry my bad how can i make it up to you
like that was always me because that's
just who i am yeah like i'm never the
starter of anything i'm always the guy
who gets gets it takes it and then when
i respond people are like you can't do
that like what do you mean i'm just
responding um and it's just you know
look it's it's uh i think in life you
wanna you wanna make people
recognize to make the right decisions
and make the right choices and don't
bully anybody don't come down on anybody
let's just try to do this and have fun
i used to say to people all the time by
the way if you're racing next to me
this is not your career is it really
that serious
i'm doing this for fun and i'm not good
enough to make it to the top so
if you're racing next to me there's a
good chance you're not making it either
so let's just leave it and let's have a
great time let's respect each other
let's keep going
oh well i think you're undermining your
talent but so where does where does
acting fit into this because like i'm
hearing about like
you know boys and growing up and the
banter and the fighting and the racing
and the you know like where does acting
fit into this so here's a very
interesting thing that i that i've that
i always look at right
it all makes total sense to me
right
because
acting is the only
job
right
where
truly
second place is the first loser
only one person gets the job oh i see
what you're saying yeah okay
so you're fighting for the win
and nothing else yeah because nothing
else matters
the guy who
was going for my role who finished in
last place
and the dude who
just didn't get it and was the next
person in line
there's no difference
so the mentality of win or don't care is
how i live my life how i live with
everything i only know that you either
win or you're lost
second place doesn't matter
it's like
talladega nights when he says dad you
said if you ain't first you're last and
he goes
my stupid son he's like you could be
third or fourth or shoot you could be
fifth
you can i love those raising movies
they're so great greatly terrible but so
so with the acting
right it was always about
winning it and i and i say this all the
time the the job
in the industry right
your job is to audition
that's what being an actor is
right you get it you get it
you if you get it
that's the bonus
right but the job is
auditioning you gotta learn your lines
you figure it out you create whatever it
is you're gonna do you go into that
audition space wherever it might be and
you deliver
and if you deliver the best
you get the job now you get the bonus of
doing the work
right so
for me it was like i gotta go win today
right i gotta go win i gotta go be this
person i gotta become somebody else
today and
and i was very fortunate because i
literally worked from day one
the first audition ever went on i got
and so
i in my mind only knew
you go to win this
you go into that room and you go in you
be whatever it is that you need to be
right no holds barred whatever they ask
you to do you go do it and you deal with
a smile and you deliver
and so you know i was fortunate enough
to
to deliver on
you know
some impactful roles that um gave me an
incredible life and um and i and i feel
blessed and fortunate that i was you
know even put in the position to go in
you know and to get and to give myself
an opportunity to to win those roles
when when
um
i switched to a different agency many
years ago and the first
meeting i had with this agent that i
ended up going with his name was john
stovis um
and he he said to me
all i can do as your agent
is give you a chance to succeed
but you got to go succeed
nobody's going to do like we could be at
the bible with caa which is the biggest
kind of you know talent agency in the
world
we can't get you work
you get yourself work
we're just going to give you the
opportunity to get that work and that's
and that's the way i've always looked at
it's my job to go in and deliver and you
know with acting it's just it was easy
for me to become somebody else
it was easy for me to
you know
as as as we've gone through this
interview it's hard for people to
imagine that the person who's saying all
this
played carlton
right like it just
they don't equal up that's because i'm
playing somebody else i become somebody
i live that life i literally become that
person and i i i deliver what i think is
a comedic most of the time performance
of that person and and my comedy really
is
you know
people live at like a six or a seven
on tv you got to be a nine or ten in
terms of energy you take it yeah it get
to the end of where it's almost too much
right and so you know i can't live it's
i can't be on screen at six or seven i
gotta be at nine or ten
and so that's all i ever did i mean even
when i do like i mean i'm obviously not
full on acting but let's say there's a
take for a commercial or anything you
name it like something little and then
they're like all right let's do one more
take well for safety which always means
that was okay but maybe there's better
in you right right always um and then i
and so
and then when i say would you like me to
like really would you like me to overact
and they're like sure
and they always love the overacting they
just love it they love the oh my gosh
and the dramatization and they love it
you know and it's like
because
there's that little person in the back
of our head that says but don't look
like a fool
right so you you you stop yourself short
of
being too big always
that is every person in this world that
is their instinct is to stop short
okay when did overacting and looking a
fool and being afraid you might look a
fool when did that pay off and you were
like i'm so
you know there it is i'm you know i i
was worried but holy [ __ ] it worked
literally after
when i was on broadway
like
at 12.
it was like
because
theater
musical
not a drama
i'm the tap dance kid
you've got to talk to that person
in row 38
you got to talk to that person and
you've got to figure out how to project
to that person while still being in the
role
when i got to tv
they all kept trying to turn the knobs
down
it was always all right just bring it
down a little bit more just play just a
little less a little i was always 10 10
right always and then it was like nah
let's let's throw a seven in here every
once in a while and i was like seven
you're like i mean anyone could do that
i was like look
missing the point but really but that
but but then i learned oh it's variety
right you got to have highs and lows and
sometimes the lows need to be here and
sometimes moments need to play
incredibly true and incredibly real and
small and then sometimes i need to play
big well all my moments on fresh prints
that are memorable are big moments
right they're 10 10 moments and what i
learned while doing fresh prince would
be
oh
i need to go to the 5
to allow will to go to the nine
so that i don't take away from his
moment
so sometimes the still
is
the setup for the big
ka boom
yeah i need to be the cur for his boom
right so so it's it's literally i
learned that as time went along but it
was literally from
first time performing in front of a
large audience was go big or go home
right go deliver it all which is why
most likely when people talk about like
well why haven't you had a film career
i'm like because i'm too big for film
right like i haven't learned how to do a
two hmm
it's very difficult yeah like you like
to be because i mean i'm guessing again
because i'm not in film but
it's very it's it's you're not it's not
as much presenting it's kind of more
like um
actually catching you having a
conversation you know it's like a moment
caught as opposed to supposed to be
natural as opposed to which naturals
naturals a lot lower than a ten right
very much very much so and you have to
drop it all the way down you've got to
gotta really take it small and the way i
always like to say it is
the difference between
me being
here
and me being here oh yeah yeah right i
mean that's a visual i'm talking from
here i better not have an awful lot
going on
but if i'm back here
i can talk with my hands i can so that's
it's kind of the closer you get
the smaller you get
the wider you get
the larger you get
and so the the film medium to me is such
a smaller
like picture frame
that
it's really difficult for me to hit all
my notes
yeah
did you want to do film
oh i think as an actor you want to do
everything right right i mean especially
like it seems like um
some sort of graduation right i don't
know it just seems like when you do this
then you do that right right i mean look
at the end of the day if you become a
film star you become a movie star and
you basically you know you know get to
call your shots for the rest of your
life right whereas tv star you're always
walking into an into that room
auditioning yeah and so of course you
know would have loved to but i just
didn't i didn't have that
thing
that allowed me to go to that small
place while still delivering a big
moment never learned how to do that
right so what do you do so because i
think this is something i've even done
in my own life where you just end up
realizing kind of what your
talents are like what your personality
is and and then where that fits in you
know for me i i always thought something
like when i'm done with racing all the
cooking show i love to cook that would
be really fun i know you love to cook
yeah yeah i've cooked for you and
it was great
thanks but i
but then i thought then i did a couple
of segments and you know i've done
plenty of different cooking shows and
been on but then
i realized i'm like i don't think i can
do that i'm not i'm not that funny i'm
not that
light i'm not that uh bubbly i'm like
super serious which is where the podcast
came in because when it came to talking
to people and getting like going deep
i'm like oh yeah i'm like i love talking
i love that i'm so interested that is
far more my jam than it is to talk about
hey and take a cup of this and pour in a
tablespoon of that and mix that up and
why is that going over there susie
you're having a good you know like i i
just can't do it and so i learned where
i fit in so where does it where do i
hear you but but i'll say
i don't fully agree with that
in that
it's not about
the
it's about a team
right you've done
single person sports with teams behind
you right right right right
it's about a team if i were to put you
with
two or three chefs
and you all got in the kitchen and
played
i bet you would be really really fun
in those moments because it wouldn't be
about
you having to be fun you would just have
fun
inside of a world that you actually
enjoy
because you enjoy the process
of making a meal if that was the if that
was the circumstance it would take you
out of what you know you're comfortable
with because it's that same thing can
you go beyond
that moment of like i know that this is
where i'm comfortable
this is my six
even though you take your six to the ten
because this is what you're also really
good at
you feel comfortable with it whereas
that you're less comfortable i think you
would be fantastic on a cooking show but
that's just me but um but with that you
know and your wife should do it angela
can do the baking and all the desserts
and i'll cook the maine i mean like come
on
right now yeah
so where did you find that your talents
and your ability to be at a 10 like
where does that fit in where did you
find a home for that after because when
did fresh prince when was i mean fresh
prince ended
a long time ago uh
1996. yeah there you go so i mean
there's been a lot of time and and
you've done plenty of other things but
you know where did you find that that
personality fit in
well i think
you know the beautiful thing about
sitcom work
is your rehearsal process
the rehearsal process is everything in
sitcom if you don't have a good director
that knows how to
lift up the rehearsal process
you typically don't have a show right
on fresh prints our rehearsals
was everything
we created
magic in rehearsals that then made it to
screen
right a lot of things that we did ad
libbing and playing around the director
sometimes would be like just keep going
and you would just like play
and you we always had writers who would
be sitting on set because they learned
that writing what you did whatever we
did they would write it down and then
all of a sudden the next day it's in the
actual script in the context of the
scene
and so
you learn i learned very quickly that go
go play find it
do whatever go 10-10
right
there are so many things that like the
the the uh there was a there was a um
madeleine cripe was a was the the the
coordinator camera coordinator for the
show
and she used to have a a saying for me
and it was
way over the top
made me laugh
right because that was me and she would
always be like that was way over
made me laugh
so
like do you bring it back and it's not
as funny or do you go all the way but it
made you laugh
right
it worked on fresh prince for me to go
over because
we looked into the camera or will did
the moment that happened
it allowed for anything
huh it wasn't those moments when it
would be like
right
immediately made it okay
to do anything you can go way over the
top you can do anything it doesn't
matter this isn't real
and as soon as the audience knew it
wasn't real we had a license to do
whatever we want so i could go 10 10 all
day long
because
like like realistically
would i really come down the staircase
and just turn on the radio and go into a
big dance routine
i don't know anybody
actually do that
no but once will looks into the camera
and goes
now that can happen because it's not
real you get to come into our family
this fake family and play
yeah is that kind of how the office does
it is any like is any look to camera
kind of like licensed to license to go
it's it's licensed to to not be real not
be real
cool yeah
it's a true license the moment anybody
looks at it
it's this ain't real
this ain't real we're looking at you
we're looking at you sitting on your
couch in your living room this isn't
real
so
we're about to do something real silly
and stupid that isn't real but
come come for the ride it's gonna be fun
yeah right it's ridiculous but it's
funny but it's funny right and that and
it's it's it's understanding
the moments and the and the the the
triggers for people at home
that allow them
to
let go of reality let go of what should
be real should be played real now we
played real moments all the time
but
they allow you to go over the top yeah
right you couldn't imagine the friends
cast really going over the top
right they went to the limit but they
wouldn't go over the top because
that was supposed to feel real right
right they don't there's no uh it was
almost like the look to the camera is
like breaking character of going like
i'm in character and then he looks cam i
go the same
hey i'm
i'm out of character for a moment watch
this right and back in
yeah immediately it changes it changes
the relationship with the audience
so
that is a huge that was a huge part of
why we were able to do things and why i
still think today in syndication it
still does so well because
that wasn't real
right right that also allowed will smith
at the time
most people don't think about this
at the time
actors on television weren't allowed to
become movie stars
there was a hard line
that if you were a tv actor you were a
tv actor you were a movie star you were
a movie star and they never crossed
right in the 70s 80s and early 90s the
moment will looked into the camera he
could go be anybody else right right
because he was showing like
gosh wow i'm not i'm not this dude i'm
wink wink i can be anybody cause right
now i'm about to do something real out
of character
wow
that's fun you will look at television
and movies differently right yeah uh
everyone will by the way that's
listening to this i was like here's the
curtain come look behind it
what a time how many years was the show
we actually only did six seasons six big
years that led into life basically right
you know after that was done what what
were the what were the i mean what were
the big lessons because that's a big
life change
well
the the real lesson
was
things come to an end
cherish him when you can which is a
beautiful lesson
yes cherish this moment this moment will
never happen again for you
recognize it when we when we finished
our last season
and
we're all standing on that stage knowing
that this is the last time that we'll
all be together like this
we'll see each other we're all friends
we all love each other
but
this will never be like this again in
your life
and
when you get home and wake up tomorrow
morning
your life will be different
remember cherish and enjoy it and that
last day that last taping that last week
that whole the whole week we just took
it all in and enjoyed it and enjoyed
every moment and enjoyed every moment
with everyone and and it was it was a it
was an incredible
time but the lesson ultimately was you
know this is going to come to an end and
when it does
now you got to move on to the next part
of your life and what does that look
like and most of us you never know what
that looks like well you don't yeah you
don't you can try and create it but you
don't always know for sure so what has
that made you do different moving
forward in your life whether it be
work or relationships or family or kids
or
you know
what what has what have you how has
things been different since then knowing
that so young i mean you were in your
20s right yeah i mean there were a lot
of different
you know let's say you know parts of my
growth and in my life and um and and in
all of those
i i
i lived life
right like i really lived life i loved
life
racing
became
part of
my life not on camera i didn't go there
with camera crews taping me like if you
imagine today some television star going
to doing a race thing it'd have like it
become a reality show it wasn't a
reality show it was like my life and i
just do things that i enjoyed yeah that
i loved to do that made me you know
passionate right and when racing kind of
went away you know it was like then turn
into golf right and it's like
all the time golf golf golf i can't get
enough golf i can't get enough of that
feeling that competitive feeling that i
get but also the love of something like
that um and so
i i i went i went heavily on fun
right um
and then
you know you reach a certain point
certain age where you're like
okay
fun enough with the fun right and
luckily for me that's when angela came
into my life right and
turned me into a much better person that
it wasn't about the fun it wasn't about
you know any of that it was like
hey we're gonna we're in love and we're
gonna have kids and we're going to love
our kids we want to be with our kids and
we're going to you know family first and
all of that um
and like you know
a year and a half ago
middle to pandemic you know stuff like
her walking in and saying hey let's go
buy an rv
and me going what obviously i'm totally
going to ask about the rv
but i'm like what like what do you want
rv world tours right what do we do what
are you talking about
but like
one of the things i've learned is wow
there is a beautiful country that we
live in
that have so many beautiful things to
offer
and to be able to go like this last trip
we went up to glacier national park yeah
that might be one of the most beautiful
places in this country period
right and it's amazing to go up there
and of course we have little kids so we
can't really do the hikes as much as we
would like to and and one day we'll do
that but like just going to see
such picturesque beautiful places um
that's what she's brought into my life
she's brought me she you know leveled it
down got me now i can do it too
right i couldn't do it now and now and
like into in a year and a half from now
you'll be a movie star
we'll see um but but the idea of
you know really
getting down to the the core of really
the person that i am which is
about happiness about joy right all of
the fun and all of the you know having a
great time and then you know you know
we're never gonna have this moment again
so let's enjoy it right all that now
it's like you know what we are gonna
have this moment again it's just gonna
look different um
right it's just not gonna it's not gonna
be this moment but we're gonna have
these moments we're gonna share
wonderful times with friends we're gonna
you know on our road trip stop at your
house and and and have dinner right
we're gonna we're gonna have we're gonna
right we're gonna have these moments in
our lives that you can share and and
and you know it doesn't have to happen
every day
but you cherish those moments you you
stop and
you know as they say you stop and smell
the roses and that's
really the the transition that has
changed for me that is that it's like i
can just go sit somewhere i couldn't sit
before and i can sit and just and just
be
and and
you know she's been the most incredibly
supportive person with my business with
with that but it's really just like i am
a better person
because i was fortunate enough to meet
her
you know the experiences that you're
having right now are priceless with the
kids young and being able to have
freedom and traveling and seeing places
together and having new experiences
together i mean that's just gold and
it's so cool that you know you both are
just such a good team
what do you want to teach your kids
in this whole journey especially
when you have this immersion time
because anybody that doesn't know bus
live it is full immersion yes you you're
in
um
the i want them
to find joy in the smaller things
i want them to
truly
you know
at this age all they're doing is wanting
to run and play and and tackle and fight
and all of that right i want them to
recognize what's when something is
beautiful
and
there are moments when
you know we're driving in the rv and
i'll say guys come on up here check this
out and they'll come up and like my
older son aj will be like wow
and like those are the moments that i
want them to remember forever i want
them to be able to say wow
we've seen some incredibly beautiful
things that that that this countryside
has to offer and
you know
a mo you know days don't go by when they
realize that the the reason they even
have this is because you got to put in
the hard work right like i'm able to buy
an rv
and go riding around the country because
i've worked my butt off to get that
all the good wonderful things in your
life will come from your hard work enjoy
what you see take it in i always like to
say as an actor
i can't
portray something i've never seen that's
right it's fact i mean right like i can
make it up
but how real is it don't know
right so the more people you meet the
more places you see the more experiences
you have
is what makes you full
and that you can bring to anything you
do in life
anything no matter what it is whether
it's on tv movie whether it's you know
sitting at a desk um you're gonna bring
your experiences to whatever it is you
do to whatever you're passionate about
and this road trip the constant road
trips are part of that you know we we
say all the time you can read about
mount rushmore in a book
but it's really kind of cool to go see
it in person
so let's just go see it and experience
it and that's done you know you don't
have to rely on the books to be
reporting on anything right you actually
just go see it for yourself yep yep
you're not taking someone else's uh take
on it you're just seeing it
and experience you know it's wow and
crazy it's much smaller than i thought i
know my parents were just there they
went to my parents went to sturgis okay
yeah because you know they're bikers yep
um they're anything really um
and they they drove by that and they
they they did last year because they
went and they said it is smaller than
you'd think
it just i you know i was like women
that's it
massive but you know
it's kind of hard to you know chisel
faces in the rock
sense after you see it and you go yeah
yeah they kind of had to do this and you
know didn't take them 100 years so where
do you fit in in golf in
rving around the country and
all the fun things that you do where do
you fit into where where does work start
because you do funniest home videos
which is cool and so funny i mean who
didn't watch that growing up right me
too
right um loved it um but i i
i have the greatest job on the planet
because um one i just get to go and
laugh at videos right like even right
before we came on i was actually
prepping uh voice over for tomorrow for
afe because my first day is tomorrow and
the
the the beauty of that is is that
we tape throughout the year
right so so that the videos remain fresh
i might work this day and then i might
work again
like in two weeks and then i might work
again in another two weeks and so it's
spread out through the year so i just
kind of look at my schedule and go okay
i got a two week hole got it this is my
window right so let's go take a trip for
those two weeks sure and then come back
right golf is you know if i'm not on set
i can go play golf
right so
i i fit that in
often um
but
that that that just fits in where it
fits in you know i mean i'm passionate
about it i've got a simulator in my
guest house scottsdale's calling your
name by the way i just want you to know
that y'all moving out here
it's calling there's got to be more golf
courses here than anywhere i keep saying
to angela that
i would love
arizona
she's like yeah but it's so hot in the
summer i was like yeah but
we get two places
yeah i'm i'm working on it
we're working on it because i know you
keep saying it on the other side um
i love your wife she's like my super
girl my hippie girlfriend who knows
everything about when it comes to emfs
and food and all the things and i know
she keeps you healthy and well
and uh i think she's great and i think
you should move out here so we can hang
out and be friends i i think uh i think
i'm working on it with you
yeah well i hope you come out soon and
in the meantime you know keep doing your
keep doing the keep doing the the the
living life thing you know and being
joyful and having fun and teaching your
kids what it's like to
work hard play hard
i said i'm thank you and i'm gonna
absolutely you know i'm just gonna keep
doing me and keep and keep loving it and
and you know i i feel so blessed that i
have this life and i've got amazing fans
around the country who show me love all
the time and you know and more
importantly i've got great family and
great friends that continue to support
me and continue you know lifting me up
um and and all i'm gonna do is keep
being me and keep loving loving
everybody that i have in my world
sounds like a good job
thanks everybody for listening to the
pretty intense podcast today i hope you
enjoyed it if you like what you heard
today and you want to hear more please
click on the subscribe button